yes endo and welcome to this Rapids game
on leeches playing Bahamas Bahamas la
day probably I just like to feed time
and I'll get the box you bind like every
other game okay what can I do
it's the best line here c4 and d4
yeah Bahamas la d 96 expect 96 no but
this is of course also fine yeah I had a
couple of that was recently with white
and black here in the leeches rapid
videos normally d6 now is played after
which a castle yeah here black main
choices are Bishop takes give a Knight
takes d4 on the 57 so let's see what he
does here we should be sixes one way to
do it that's not very precise actually
so he plays it I don't quite remember
how this is done rook C 1 or B 3 white
place with f4 here
b3 oak see 1 or F form one of those
can I don't want to spend a minute now
or so just play the salad you're looking
stuff and then see what happens
Queen 85 is now the most common idea and
then f4 is right
still this a six but ticks ticks again
its quest for this is right anyway so
let's play it one important point is
that glue this move prevents ninety
seven and I can take player five and win
a piece so it limits blacks options
quite considerably let's see Queen a5 I
think I'll play King h1 in order to
answer blue five with f5 that looks that
looks questionable that looks
questionable the Bishop LX me Lex
squares this is why I think it looks
strange and ninety five is putting him
into into a fork so let's focus a little
bit and see if we have something good
against this
[Music]
queen d3m that let would actually
support that he might be he might plan
Bishop g4 here also but then I can just
take and and be better probably so queen
d3 intending also a5 b5 f 5 BC form
that's a bit of a that's some kind of
chaos am queen d3 be fun maybe take
first M and then at five admins material
yeah that move looks good let's do it
I'm threatening f5 and I think Bishop
you fall I just take we should reform
Bishop takes you for Queen takes Bishop
f6 Bishop f6 95 that should be better
for what right none f6 Knight b6 let's
see he does play it okay I also have
Bishop takes of 68 22 so I also have f5
this is also a move but in general I
like this this must be a bit better for
me but I actually wonder is after Queen
takes if I want to take on f6 Knight
takes okay
okay so I'm taking I guess I'm taking
[Music]
I'm undecided between playing 95
immediately or tape on g7 and then 95 95
takes Queen takes maybe five
it also looks bad and looks pretty bad
yeah okay let me put it on d5 does he
have an 85 now no 96 looks too bad
one problem is that the night on G form
can adjust easily retreats back to G to
f6 as this would absolutely kill off his
pawn structure would be fairly terrible
fairly terrible this is probably some
some rhetorical figure said would that
rabbit or could figure things like
alliteration or a euphemism is that is
that okay so he does play them off yeah
I'm not entirely happy yeah if this I
should have figured it out I'd say if
this is good or not so night night to be
six and
[Music]
okay Knight b6 Knight b6 Queen go go
where
98 most likely if I then take one c8 you
can take one you for this is the thing
that I dislike 9pc and I don't really
have like tonight b6 Queen d8 I don't
have a good square for that Bishop I
should have taken on g7 I would have
been a lot easier really a lot like b6
creator took em and move them
yeah night CAT takes d4 and my knight is
no squares okay a seven but that looks
bad huh
maybe I should take actually I mean
Bishop III and Bishop F to suck and
going back to be - I don't know I mean
okay maybe if he takes and loop checks
okay this is actually somewhat
interesting if I go here and he takes I
also have 96 winning in exchange okay
took me ages to come to this decision
yeah I don't know
as I should have thought about this a
bit more that is going e 5 and this is
this Bishop C 3 is actually good
solution
so b5 yeah okay and then I'd be six he
prevents that's that's nice for him so
what to do I mean check here to check
valve
and five the chick is annoying relevant
it threatens to take on our forum at
five is the move I went to Clara Queen a
seven actually then and then you would
exchange on f2y I have 97 so I will get
the exchange back but I don't like that
I'm losing losing control here that much
such a nicely coordinated position and
now it looks a tad Matthew yeah but f5
is the move I want to play a role in
Queen a7 I don't know if I can but that
that exchange sack looks looks wrong
look to me like it should work
anyway to again threaten this a 96 can
just move the King and after Queen a7i
Queen f3 or so this could be an idea
okay
now probably go play some f5 stuff maybe
they had lost control over this
pollution I don't like that I should
have just instead of this original
Shahrukh just taken one g7 that was much
easier much easier to play they I expect
them to take on c4 give me that week C
pawn it's proving not a huge deal
Queen a7 so you don't care about 97 it
seems on that b6 for that matter but
okay I mean he just he just basically
gives me the exchange so I'm taking it
a big issue is actually then after Luke
takes the aid I can take only five and
open up against f7 so
that okay okay so look f7 and I also
have Queen go Sam
Oh h3 sorry h3 that's night h6 down at
age 16 okay it says something really
that why I cannot play with yourself not
really I think at night on the gear
putting this night on h6 is also
completely if you have to do that is
also completely terrible twin g3 looks
good in that regard attack this and and
this doesn't work and this I can take is
five yeah it looks very strong that
looks very strong
I know go reply yeah so here how to take
it
whipped eggs I guess yeah it's good
ninety-four take 2025 chick and f6 is
just hanging so it's not quite not clear
what this move is I can put more
pressure Queen f4 and things like that
let's let's basicly over at least I
don't see anything much whoops you four
[Music]
yeah Bishop takes Bishop chains look-see
for Quincy for and I cannot take because
of background stuff okay so how do I
know Bishop f6 looks looks easy I told I
don't see anything
will I cook till 1:00 or so I come out
taking a taking should be technically
quite easy so let's take it
so check here can you sell me five I can
attack this f7 pawn which will be
difficult to them to defend actually so
it looks good
walk Wiener for simply that's also a
good more queen F form
how does he do how does the end of that
cannot move the bishop hoops you wanna
have Queen f6 intermediate move
[Music]
books is six I will take it and play
five to take a seven next I know that
was the easiest way it looks it looks
quite convincing
so I was thinking just to take you know
that is good enough for William he had
f7 will fall didn't really have a good
square also I'm going to win the Bishop
immediately on or made or something to
just just too much should the eight
queen of seven the queen of eight
picking up the bishop yeah he he running
tonight
ninety-seven check that it wasn't a
clear situation at all I don't think it
was
yeah it's too late
you know the bishop has no squares
those I can just take we should be cell
might take f7 and to Bishop and Bishop
Diego yeah it is
the piece is dropping and no we're going
to look at the game first no rematch so
let's have a look look at this game and
let's see what the engine is coming up
with for med school here yeah it looks
good so I'm there should be six I
couldn't quite remember yeah what the
what the right way to do it is in the
move on white clothes like B 3 hooks C 1
F for something like that so I started
with look C 1 probably not terrible
maybe not the best C 80386 F for let's
kind of clear and now this an engine
also dislikes it and wants to play h3
this is a move they thought about just
like completely kill off Bishop g4 word
then I felt it's not such a big deal and
it's probably right maybe still actually
could be more powerful so I'm happy with
the caption this and the engine gives
both moves as roughly of roughly equal
value still it's easier to play this as
idiom now you don't have to worry all
that much not stuff like that because
you can just check thank you for 5 to
take pawn takes and then just just go
back this is easier now h3 is the big
threat
Knight has no new big squares this is
just very nice for white
I mean maybe what I did is just equally
good but I couldn't I didn't like that I
missed the whole the whole thing h3 huh
I didn't think about that
that's bad the engine actually thinks my
move was fine you should see through it
there were a couple of alternatives this
is really a funny that this is bad yeah
after Queen d8 I have no good movie I
can take c8 but he takes this and then
my knight has no way out
simply trapped I mean a7 dropped that's
no square I am can just pick it up I was
a bit of a bit of a gamma I couldn't do
that this is what annoyed me that I
don't have this move there and I'd be
six okay so I went to see three he went
b5 and after I'd keen to edge one that
move is not mentioned by the engines if
that's not a good sign
engines anyone suggests to h3 or g3 m to
go to g2 King edge one is supposed to be
a bit better than awful wild so takes
takes yeah and I I add Queen a seventh
that was what I had on the radar and
then tended to play the Queen to f3 or
g3 that was my idea
the engine gives f5 gap this was an
alternative so just allow this and just
say okay I remain in the position here
is good this is tough to evaluate down I
mean the bishop looks bad but it's not
my position doesn't feel very harmonious
yeah I have unprotected pieces here and
a big background and so on so this
wouldn't have been an easy decision
I mean this is the engine last but it's
not easy for for Yuma to evaluate it
looks
a bit scary with the big black going and
so on but obviously that doesn't seem to
be anything yeah that would have been
the the main continuation I think I want
to play Queen gf3 or Queen to g3 and it
also seems like I'm slightly better what
goes back this takes clicks gigs animes
that this is just how the pond
it looks like wirelessly right a lot
better actually h3 kissing where maybe
then it's really a turd it's a nice
corner habit maybe not enough to do to
get something substantial yeah cleaning
for words playing it just blunders
Bundesbank basically F takes II was
simple move context yeah look f7 is
given a stronger yeah I mean that means
it's not that I saw the move but I
didn't like the looseness of that this
is a very simple way of doing it the
knight is attacked
yeah h5 is supposed to be better but I
didn't just play h3 this this and this
wins very very very easily it's an
exchange up and he has a very bad night
I would seems like a Miss checkmates
okay and I made in 14th okay okay so
this and now there was some made in 40
know what this should have six era okay
we should take and Queen d6 now is
checkmate yeah well okay this is like
winning winning so easily
yeah so I didn't find a check made but
it was it was certainly enough to win
the game okay I hope you enjoyed the
game thanks for watching